[संगीत]
खुदा
सो हेलो गैस मैं ए गया हूं फिर से अपना एक
लेकर
हमारा एसक्यूएल का तो देखो आज का जो टॉपिक
है वह थोड़ा सा इंपॉर्टेंट भी है और थोड़ा
सा समंदर को हार्ड भी होगा आपको सो आज के
सेशन में आपको कंसंट्रेशन पूरा बनाकर रखना
है इसी तरफ में ठीक है जितनी सदस्य आप
अपने कष्ट को पटाने की कोशिश करते हो इस
से अच्छा आज आपको देखने का है इस सेशन को
क्योंकि ये एक आपको थोड़ा सा इंटरेस्टिंग
से भी लगेगा अगर आप लोगों के मां में अगर
क्वेश्चन नहीं आया तो
की ये चीज कैसे हो रही है वो चीज कैसे
मतलब ये कैसे करें वो कैसे करें तो अगर
आया है तो आज उसके सॉल्यूशंस भी होंगे
ठीक है तो चलते हैं आज का अपना टॉपिक जो
है वो बाद में रिव्यू करूंगा पहले अपन को
जब प्रॉब्लम्स आई है ना उससे बात करते हैं
ठीक है
कनेक्ट
सिस्टम
सैलरी
है वो मैं निकाल सकता हूं कैसे
सिलेक्ट
के साथ अगर मैं यहां पर नाम भी लिखूंगा
तो यह कम नहीं करेगा
ठीक है ना
तो फिर भी अपनी इसका यहां पर नाम हम कैसे
ला सकते हैं वह अपना
जन वाले हैं तो उसे टर्म को मां बोलते हैं
अपना
क्या होता है
तो उसे रिजल्ट के बेस में अपन ने ऊपर की
क्वेरी लिखने हैं ठीक है और वेयर के बाद
में उसे सीरियल के बेस पर कम करते हैं
ठीक है तो यह अपनी
क्लास के अंदर लिखी जाति है ठीक है
तो अपना जो क्वेश्चन था की यार की
मैक्सिमम सैलरी वाले का मुझे नाम चाहिए
डिटेल
सैलरी इक्वल्स तू
सिलेक्ट
मैक्स
सैलरी फ्रॉम
सब कुछ एंप्लॉयमेंट
सैलरी वाली
जब इसका रिजल्ट आएगा तो यहां पर सैलरी
चाहते हैं वो कर सकते हैं
आप लोगों को
[संगीत]
क्लास परिसर
वाले का अगर अपन को डिटेल चाहिए तो क्या
करेंगे अपने बस यहां पर कोई भी कुछ ऐसा
चीज नहीं था जिसके वजह से अपन निकाल सकते
हैं तो इसके लिए अपने क्या करेंगे ये एक
क्वेरी लिखेंगे
ठीक है ना उसके अंदर भी एक और कर रही होगी
तो जो यहां पर वैल्यू बटन करेगी
मैं कोशिश करूंगा की आराम आराम से समझाऊं
ठीक है ना
तो प्लीज ऑफिस
तो यह होती है
तो अपने को 95000 का आउटपुट दिखा रहा था
तो होगा कहना जब भी कोई रीजन हो जाएगी तो
यहां पर लिखकर ए जाएगा 94
लिख देता हूं मैं यहां पर
लिखा हुआ ए जाएगा
क्या चीज है यह कौन सी बोला था नाम है यह
नहीं थे
आजकल क्या कुछ समझ में आएंगे
जरूर
ऊपर से चला जाएगा
की
[संगीत]
मुझे चाहिए सेकंड हाईएस्ट बंदे का नाम
की जिनका सेकंड हाईएस्ट सैलरी है
सैलरी
इस लेस थान 95000
98000 से कम सैलरी है उनमें से मैक्सिमम
कौन सा है यहां पे दिखाओ बट यार अपन को
95000 मालूम थोड़ी होगा क्योंकि जब हम
टेबल बनाया है तो वालुज अपन थोड़ी डालते
हैं अपन तो बस टेबल बनाते हैं वैल्यू
डालना अपन प्रोग्रामिंग करते हैं तो
पोग्रामिंग या फिर अपना जो भी डेवलपमेंट
अपन करते हैं तो उसके अंदर वालुज अपने
इनपुट करते हैं ठीक है ना तो अपनी 19
दाल दी या फिर आपने मतलब किसी कंपनी के
लिए बनाया और वो कंपनी के ओनर ने ₹1 लाख
सब में से मैक्सिमम
इतना वाला क्वेरी क्या करके मेरा तो 95000
निकाल के देगा तो उसके बाद में जाकर यह जो
बड़ा वाले क्वेरी है ये अपन को 9000 निकाल
के देगा
इसका
दिखाने के बाद में सिलेक्ट स्टारी =
अपन ऐसे एग्जीक्यूट करके देख सकते हैं
इसलिए मैं बार-बार पूछ रहा हूं
थोड़ा सा दीप में करेंगे
ठीक है ठीक है तो बहुत अच्छी बात है
तो चलो आगे करते हैं
हां पारस भाई एक मेरे हर सेशन तो
प्लीज आप मुझे एक बार एक्सप्लेन करोगी की
अपना
लेफ्ट आउटर क्या होता है
मतलब मैं थोड़ा सा रिवीजन के हिसाब से की
कल का रिपीट करना है
मुझे मेरे क्वेश्चन का आंसर का रही है की
आप लेफ्ट आउटर को जानते हैं की क्या होता
है
वेटिंग पर रिप्लाई चाट
टेबल
के सारे रिकॉर्ड
दिखाएगा जो अपना मैचिंग रिकॉर्ड राहत है
यार
मतलब सच में
लव यू आई लव यू
अच्छा लगता है
की नहीं
आप मोहम्मद
पारस भाई चले गए हैं
मैं देखो यार मतलब कौन-कौन है जो ग्रुप
में मतलब कुछ ऐसे लोग हैं जो ग्रुप में
बहुत ज्यादा ही ऐसे बोलते हैं लेकिन रियल
लाइफ में कुछ नहीं करते हैं
फंक्शन अपना कोई एक आउटपुट लॉगिन
ठीक है तो अगर मां लो की अपन मल्टीपल
आउटपुट हो उसे कैसे में अपन को अगर सफेद
रंग करनी होगी तो उसको मल्टीपल रोस्ट करिस
बोलते हैं
ठीक है ना
तो सबसे पहले मैं कम करता हूं
सॉरी सॉरी
इसमें से कोई भी अगर रिजल्ट अपने इसके
अंदर आता है
अन्य क्या करेगा
अपना 1995 90
क्या करेगा ना ये देखो ये अपना वालुज है
मल्टीपल वालुज है एक कर दो अपने करी ऑन
करके निकाल सकते थे लेकिन वो तुरंत हो
जाता ठीक है मैंने इसको ऐसे करके दिखाए
आपको ठीक है तो ये अपना लिस्ट ले लिए इसके
अंदर मल्टीपल वालुज पड़ी है ना इनमें से
कोई भी वैल्यू में से अगर अगर ग्रेटर होता
है सैलरी का वैल्यू तो उसका
95000 लिखा हुआ है एक जगह पे
ठीक है
मुझे यहां पे लेक देगा तो ये देखो ये सारे
वालुज 85000 से बड़े है और अगर मैं यहां
पर 95000 लिखना हूं
ठीक है तो यहां पर
दिया नहीं
था
ये बड़ा होगा लेकिन अपन यहां पर अब
कॉन्सेप्ट समझो चीज होगा की अन्य कम कैसे
कर रहा है अन्य मतलब इनमें से कोई सी भी
एक वैल्यू से अगर बड़ा होता है अपना
वैल्यू सैलरी का तो वो आउटपुट ला के देगा
अन्य का कम अन्य अपना ऐसा कम करता है
ठीक है
तो देखो अपने पास वैल्यू जितनी वैल्यू
होगी ना उन वैल्यू में से किसी भी वैल्यू
में से
चेक करेगा की सैलरी अपना
साइज दूंगा
वैल्यू में से किसी भी एक वैल्यू में से
बड़ा छोटा या जो भी अपन यहां पर देंगे
इसको वो चेक करेगा
थोड़ा सा हार्ड ग रहा हो या फिर जो भी सी
मुझे बताओ की आपको समझ में आया की नहीं
नहीं तो मैं इसको और थोड़ी फाइन समझने की
कोशिश करता हूं शायद या फिर मैं समझा नहीं
का रहा है या फिर आपका समझ में नहीं आता
मुझे इस चीज में बताओ
किसी भी एक से अगर यहां पर जयसमंद कंडीशन
देंगे इसको लॉजिकल कंडीशन देंगे
उसके हिसाब से किसी भी एक वैल्यू में से
उसके लॉजिकल कंडीशन चेक करेगा और उसके
हिसाब से जो आउटपुट आएगा ओपन को यहां ला
के देगा मैं यही आपको का सकता हूं की अन्य
क्या करता है वालुज है तो उनमें से किसी
भी एक वैल्यू में से
लॉजिकल ऑपरेशन ट्राई करेगा
लॉजिकल ऑपरेशन
[संगीत]
अच्छा
देखो
ठीक है
अच्छा सुन रहे हो अन्य का कम यह लिस्ट ऑफ
वालुज में से हर वैल्यू या किसी भी वैल्यू
में से अगर आउटपुट आता है तो आउटपुट अपन
को लाकर देगा यहां पर
यह सिंपल है
सिंपलेस्ट एग्जांपल
मैं ये समझा जा सकता है अन्य कितना वालुज
है तो किसी भी एक वैल्यू में से अगर अपन
लॉजिकल ऑपरेशन का आउटपुट आता है तो वो
आपका आउटपुट ला कर देगा लॉजिकल ऑपरेशन से
मैंने बता दिया आपको ये वाले देते हैं
लॉजिकल ऑपरेशंस
ठीक है
लेकिन जो अपन देखो जैसे अपन सैलरी इक्वल्स
तू अपन को अपन ने एक ही वैल्यू लिखने का
मौका मिलता था की ये ना 95 2018
₹1 लाख लिखना हूं
ठीक है तो यहां पर किसी भी वैल्यू ला के
देना चाहिए उसको तो अगर 10000 का आउटपुट
नहीं है तो आयरन नहीं लगेगा यहां पर वो बस
सिमुलरी अपन को आउटपुट नहीं देगा बस इतना
ही है अन्य हर इसके बाद जितनी भी वैल्यू
है ना हर वैल्यू से जाके चेक करके आउटपुट
करके देगा
बस अपन इसके ना मल्टीपल दाल सकते हैं इसको
अपन ऐसे भी समझ सकते हैं
ठीक है
अब देखो मैंने सैलरी
में करता
टूडपुरा लाकर देगा
उन सब वालुज में से चेक करेगा या सब वालुज
में से अगर कोई सैलरी बड़ा है तो ये
आउटपुट नहीं तो और पुतला के नहीं देगा वो
अगर मैं करूं तो यहां वैल्यू ला के दे
देगा यहां भाई
98495000 दोनों से छोटे वालुज कौन-कौन से
हैं 80000 80000 और 60000 ये अपने वालुज
है तो दोनों से छोटे हैं
की यहां पर
चेक करेगा की भाई दोनों में से किसी से भी
अगर वैल्यू अगर अपना बड़ा है यहां पर ठीक
है ना तो वो आउटपुट करके देगा और क्या
करेगा दोनों से बड़ा होना चाहिए भाई जो
अपन ने जितनी यहां पे वालुज दी है उन
साड़ी वालुज में से बड़ी होकर कोई वैल्यू
है अपने साइन दिया है इसलिए कोई बड़ी
वैल्यू है
तो मत ला कर दो
अब आपको अच्छे से क्लियर हो गए होंगे
आवाज अपना एड्रेस वाला
का रिजल्ट ला के देगा
अपन इसको एग्जांपल के साथ समझेंगे तो
ज्यादा अच्छे से समझ में आएगा तो पहले
सिलेक्ट
करो
ठीक है
तो अपना क्वेश्चन ऐसा है की यार कौन-कौन
से कोर्स के अंदर बच्चे एंड्राइड है वह
उनको देखने के लिए हर बच्चे का डिलीवरी है
ठीक है ना बट एक बट कुछ बच्चे ऐसे भी है
मतलब कुछ और ऐसे भी हैं जिसके अंदर कोई भी
बच्चा इनरोल नहीं है
तो उसका रिजल्ट कैसे लाकर देंगे
तो उसके लिए अपन उसके लिए एक्जिस्ट वाला
कम करेंगे
एक्सप्लेन करता हूं
अपने कोर्स टेबल में से कोर्स आईडी है
ना
अब जब ये वाली कमांड में सिंपल ऐसे ही रन
करूंगा तो क्या होगा
जल्दी बताओ कौन से जॉइन की घमंड है यह
चलो किसी का नहीं आया मैं ही होता है
लेकिन कहानी पर है ना अपना 50 नहीं आया है
ठीक है
इस कमांड को आउटपुट यह आएगा
मतलब
मैं इसको थोड़ा नीचे
जी रिकॉर्ड का आउटपुट यहां पर देखो
देखो इसके अंदर का रिकॉर्ड नहीं आया है
अपने को अपना एग्जिट के चक्कर में हो रहा
है की आपने यहां पर जो कमांड डाली
इस कमांड में से कोर्स के अंदर में से कौन
सा रिकॉर्ड अपने को दिखे रहा है ठीक है
तो यहां पर कोई भी आउटपुट नहीं आएगा लेकिन
अगर यहां पर रिकॉर्ड दिखता है तो यहां पर
आउटपुट आएगा टेबल में से
लेकिन इसको आप एक बार सोचना अभी आपको शायद
यह समझ में ना आए ठीक है
ठीक है
नोट एग्जिट लिख देंगे
भाई जिन रिकॉर्ड्स का आउटपुट दिखे रहा है
रिकॉर्ड्स में यहां पर लाकर दो तो बस लोड
नहीं दिखे रहा है उन्होंने आउटपुट उसे उन
रिकॉर्ड्स यहां पर ला दो तो इसमें कोई कम
कर देंगे की भाई इस वाले के अंदर नहीं था
अब इस वाले के अंदर 50 है
50 के अलावा बाकी है तो मैं यहां पे लेक
दे दिया
बस ये अपना एग्जिट है
थोड़ा समझना शायद मुश्किल हो गया मेरे लिए
भी और आप लोगों के साथ संबंध
तीन बार देखोगे आप अगर खुद से कमांड ऑन
करोगे मैंने शायद पहले पर्सनल मैसेज बताई
थी की आप एक बार खुद से चीज कर करके ट्राई
करके देखोगे खुद के लॉजिक बनोगे तो आपको
चीज शायद समझ में ज्यादा अच्छे से आएंगे
तो ये एक्जिस्ट और मतलब हार्ड राहत है
देखोगे तो आपको शायद थोड़ा अच्छे समझ में
आए तो अच्छी नहीं है
तो अभी लिख दो ताकि उसे चीज को सॉल्व कर
सुकून
समझ में आया था क्या करती है
उनको रन करके देखने का है ठीक है
कंपनी के पेज पर जाना है
कंपनी पोस्ट के अंदर आपको जाना है ठीक है
वैसे डेट का भी यहां पर ए जाएगा ठीक है
तो डेट का आने के बाद में आपको अपना उसके
अंदर जो ये आप कर रहे हैं अगर डेट का अगर
नहीं आता है यहां पर तब तक आप टेलीग्राम
के अंदर भी बता सकते हैं
और आपको कोई दिक्कत है
पूछो ठीक है
तो आज के लिए बस इतना ही
और बाकी सब आपको
डिस्क्रिप्शन में मिल जाएंगे सो
थैंक यू
सो प्लीज कल सब लोग
देने के लिए सो चलिए टाटा बाय बाय गुड
नाइट सबको आ